The Last Jedi received plenty of justifiable
criticism, but regardless of what people thought
of the movie as a whole, I saw a lot of people
talking about how cool this particular scene
is.
In a franchise where large explosions in space
has been done many, many times, the fact that
director Ryan Johnson was able to create an
explosion scene that felt fresh and was breathtaking
is impressive.
So what is it about this scene that makes
it so cool?
Let’s breakdown all the elements and see
what we find.
First let’s talk about the context of the
scene in the story.
The build up to this moment involves several
scenes that are being intercut.
Leading up to the explosion three separate
stories are reaching a crescendo.
This has the effect of making this explosion
feel like the fulfillment of more pieces of
the story than it actually is.
One of the pretty obvious effects used to
create the forcefulness of the impact of this
scene is the way the audio drops out entirely.
Surrounded on either side by music, dialogue
and sound effects, the suddenness of the silence
in this moment creates a heavy impact for
the audience.
But the most brilliant piece of why this explosion
looks so cool is also one of the most subtle
parts.
To understand what’s going on, we need to
talk about a technical part of cameras for
a moment.
Working with a real explosion and physical
cameras, a burst of light, like the kind that
comes from an explosion can present a challenge.
The light from the explosion is much brighter
than the ambient light of a nighttime scene
or sky, so to compensate for this a cinematographer
would have a few options.
The first would be to set the exposure like
they normally would for the scene, and just
let the bright fireball be overexposed.
JJ Abrams uses this method in The Force Awakens,
in these scenes.
Here’s a real life example, in this footage
of a nuclear explosion, the camera’s exposure
is set for a daylight scene.
Because the explosion is so much brighter,
the image is completely blown out for a few
seconds.
The second would be to set the exposure for
the brightness of the explosion and let everything
else in the scene be darker or in silhouette
as a result.
Abrams also uses this effect in this scene
from The Force Awakens.
Here’s a another real life example, because
his explosion is so much brighter than the
surrounding, when the camera is set to capture
the explosion, everything else is in complete
darkness.
The third option would be to ramp or change
the exposure as the explosion is happening.
A camera with auto exposure controls does
this, you can see it in action by pointing
your phone at a light bulb and then turning
it on.
This is the effect Rian Johnson uses in this
scene.
When you’re dealing with virtual camera
and digital effects, like Rian Johnson would
have been with this scene, it’s technically
possible to to artificially adjust the brightness
of the explosion so you don’t have the exposure
“problem” you would in real life.
This is done quite often in the Original Star
Wars trilogy and the prequels.
In this shot, if the camera were to expose
for the brightness of the explosion, we shouldn’t
be able to see the stars in the background
at all, which are comparatively dim.
This can look artificial.
Instead Johnson chooses to have the virtual
camera adjust to the brightness of the explosion
as it happens, causing a brief moment of overexposure
before the camera adjusts to the brightness
of the explosion, leaving everything else
in the scene in darkness.
Notice how the stars which can be seen before
the explosion, can’t be seen after the camera’s
exposure adjusts.
I think this subtle detail lends a realistic
quality to the sequence of shots.
Making the explosion feel grounded within
a physical reality and emphasizing how bright
the explosion actually is.
Johnson doesn’t linger on the explosion
to long, he quickly grounds the effect within
the space the character’s inhabit, which
helps place the explosion in perspective.
It’s interesting to me that a small detail
like this can be so effective.
Small details can sell a scene, and the strange
part is that they work even for an audience
member who never notices it or doesn’t know
what’s going on.
Even if you have no idea how a camera works,
whenever we use our phone camera, or any kind
of video camera, we pick up small clues about
how things look.
If the exposure of the explosion and the scene
had been artificially balanced.
Something might have looked a little bit off
to the average audience member, but the probably
wouldn’t have been able to explain why.
Recreating the limitations of a physical camera
with visual effects helps things feel more
real.
In filmmaking, details matter.
Even the small ones that only effect a few
frames.
SKILLSHARE READ:
Never stop learning.
The first 150 people to use the link in the
description below will get 2 months of Skillshare
Premium for free.
I love to learn, it’s a big part of why
I love doing this channel, I get to learn
about stuff and relay what I’m learning
to you.
This video’s sponsor - Skillshare is a great
way to learn.
Skillshare is an online learning community
with over 19,000 classes on a huge variety
of topics.
Recently I’ve wanted to improve my voice
over skills, and there are several Skillshare
classes that have been a huge help.
If you’re a viewer on this channel you might
appreciate some of the film production classes,
whether it’s editing, cinematography or
screenwriting, you’ll find a lot that will
help you get better at your craft.
Premium Membership begins around $10 a month
- but for the
first 150 people to sign up with the link
in the description, you can get 2
months of Skillshare for FREE!
These spots typically go quite quickly so
make sure to get in there